today we're talking about data catalog
the anthos sample deployment and Google
Cloud talks I'm reto Meier and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news from the safety
of our homes Google Cloud Data catalog
is a metadata management service that
can help you manage all of your data
from one interface accessible from
within the Google Cloud console data
catalog supports both technical and
business metadata providing self-service
data discovery at scale we've just added
our anthos sample deployment to the
Google cloud marketplace so that you can
explore the platform on yeren this test
environment includes a tutorial several
anthos components and a micro services
application running in a multi cluster
kubernetes environment for cloud-based
applications more regions means
improvements in both reliability and
speed for your users as high-performing
applications are better able to cater to
the needs of nearby users with the
launch of our newest region in Las Vegas
we're bringing more flexibility and
capacity to the western US as well as
three new zones with low latency high
bandwidth networking our data may be
moving around the world but most of us
are still staying safely at home
fortunately our developer relations team
is keeping the conference spirit alive
with a new online series of Google Cloud
Talks register online to add sessions
your schedule and get reminders for
upcoming events if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link any thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you